the senior writer of the mm QB for the
last couple years he's been since 2016
longtime colleague of mine from the NFL
Network good to see you Albert Brewer
how are you sir good to see you too rich
so just real quick just to I guess in a
way connect our one hour to Dan Quinn I
asked him about the new helmet rule and
and and whether there is any concern on
his part the staffs part that the NFL
officiating crew and Cruz might not all
be on the same page as to what
constitutes a hit what does not he said
he does not think that it's gonna be the
catch rule of 2018 what are you hearing
going around trying to catch about this
conversation I think there are a couple
things I think one things that they're
maybe the fans misses that they think
that all of these are going to be
objectionable III don't think what the
actual penalty is gonna be the problem
I think separating 15 yards in ejection
is gonna be the issue just like college
right right sometimes that's what it's
gonna be like I don't think you I think
we're gonna know when it's a 15-yard
penalty I think the question for the
officials is gonna be what rises to the
level of ejection here's the other
problem rich you remember when they made
every scoring play reviewable yes okay
so they make every scoring play
reviewable and what happens well now all
of a sudden officials are calling
anything that's close to scoring play
because they know they're backstop by
the reveal yes and so I think what some
coaches are worried about now is are
they gonna like just throw are they
gonna eject a lot of people early in the
season because they're not sure about
the rule and they know at least if I'm
wrong here I have the review if I'm
wrong the other way I don't have a
review but if I'm wrong that way I have
a review and so you know it'd be like
like it's the exact same thing as like
if you're close on a touchdown we're
gonna call it a touchdown because we
know we have the review and I think
we've seen this in college with the
targeting rule right where if it's close
they call targeting because they know
they're backstop by the review and what
does that do to pace of the game you
know if we're seeing a lot of these
calls early in the year because they
don't have it fully sorted out so I
think that's the biggest thing is what's
a 15-yard penalty and then what rises to
the level of being an ejection and then
the case is that if it's an ejection it
can be a suspender ball situation refine
in the met that forfeiture language that
apparently the Jets and Sam Darnell
really
get through what's going on with Rock
Juan Smith and the Bears who you were
recently visiting yeah it's so it's
interesting because that one the
language has been in their contracts
forever right so there has been language
that's related to what can cause a
player to default on a guarantee I'm
aware of about a half-dozen teams now
that have made concessions to players
saying okay we're gonna put additional
language in to protect you against the
targeting rule but the Bears are saying
is that we've always been fair to
players with this we want there's a
standard language in our contracts and
what trust us and what what they've told
Roe Kwan's people is last year we didn't
enforce it on Danny Trevathan and we
were fair with Danny Trevathan so we
want you to trust us
so then why they have it in there and
and and that's I mean look that's just a
lot of these teams are very very and and
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
either but a lot of these teams are very
firm about wanting certain language in
their conscious and in the contracts so
they have at least the option to enforce
it against players and of course the
play I mean if I'm role Quan here what
I'm thinking is like you know what
happens if in year three let's say I
have a bad injury in year two and then
in year three I'm slow getting back and
then all of a sudden I get you know
ejected from a game and now they sent me
a letter saying like they're guarantees
are voided and maybe the injury comes
back and now they can cut me in year
four and that cost me a few million
bucks like that's a real life
application all right where you know the
Bears are saying our history has always
been to be fair with players if you're a
player do you trust that I think it's a
fair question and Roe Kwan's an
interesting one because he's always been
very very principled as far as just
protecting his rights to the point where
when he was in high school he actually
didn't sign a letter of intent with
Georgia until he enrolled there because
he wanted to keep his options up but now
he committed to Georgia right but he
said I want to see where this is going I
may been like right around when you know
they were looking at a coaching change
kept his options open never signed a
letter of intent until he actually
enrolled there because you know his
principal was I want to make sure that
I'm protecting myself and you can see it
coming out again here albert prayer of
the mm QB and he's here on the Rich
Eisen show in person on the Honda inside
a report refer
for a couple segments here on our
program so I I mentioned at the top of
the show with the Baris taking on the
Ravens in the first preseason game in
honor of her locker and Ray Lewis going
to the Hall of Fame that the bat this is
the bandwagon team of 2018 bears yeah
that everyone just thanks again we saw
what admin Sean McVeigh brilliant
offensive first time head coach second
year top drafted rookie quarterback that
it's gonna be the same thing in Chicago
that we saw with McVeigh and gulf
between obviously matt Negi and mitchell
true Biscay are you sensing that as well
yeah i think there are two things at
work here one there's this new wave of
coaches it's really open minded to doing
a lot of the things that we have seen at
the college level where is like and you
know this rich like 10-15 years ago
you'd see some college concepts and NFL
people would kind of blow like that's
just college stuff that won't work up
here I think we're seeing a lot more
open-mindedness to that sort of stuff in
the NFL now one of the reasons why
Lincoln Riley at Oklahoma had almost
every team coming through there asking
to watch tape within this offseason like
teams are trying to learn what colleges
are doing to a get a schematic advantage
and be make it easier for their players
to transition and Matt naggy has been at
the front of that like you see with the
Chiefs were the last few years the way
they built for Alex Smith it was
interesting i sat down with with Nagios
probably 10 days ago and we were talking
about places that he'd stolen plays from
like I take place from here I take place
from there and one of the things I
thought that was really interesting he
said to me is like you know for the most
part the stuff we took place the the
places we took plays from were Utah when
Urban Meyer was there because that's
where Alex Smith played were Texas Tech
where Pat mahomes was playing and now
we're looking at a lot of North Carolina
tape and I think that's what gives mr.
Biscay such a good shot you know last
year with the Rams John McVay was doing
a lot of things that Jared Goff did a
cow but incorporating those sorts of
things and I think it's smart to do that
and I think what you're seeing you're
seeing procoach is sort of adapt to the
players more than you ever have in the
past
and I think because Matt's been so open
minded to that it could really benefit
men okay so bigger season in 2018 of
people who flashed in 2017 okay I just
come up
this one right doing we won't do is
start bench couple just two will just do
three here Jimmy Garoppolo mhm
Mitchell true pesky deshaun Watson I
would say the who is a biggest jump leap
biggest leap I'm gonna say Jimmy and I
know that sounds weird because he was
really good last year right I you know
his touchdown interception ratio was
seven two five seven two five like I was
stunned when I looked that up like I had
no idea it was it so I think
statistically Jimmy's got a chance to
make a great jump because this is year
two under Kyle Shanahan we saw one that
Ryan did in year 200 Kyle Shanahan
we've seen what Kyle's been able to do
for a quarterback so I think the
environment in San Francisco now I still
don't think they're there yet from a
roster standpoint but I think Jimmy's
gonna be the biggest statistical jump I
think Mitch there gonna be some bumps
probably early on huh and I think with
the Shawn they're gonna catch up to some
of the things that they were doing early
on he said I think the still think he's
gonna be a good player but I think
they're gonna be some growing pains and
he's coming back off an ACL so I put my
money on Jimmy right now he karappa and
you knew that off the top your head did
did he break pretty good did he break up
with you to go out with the porch it's
gonna be a monster season yeah like 35
touchdowns eight picks I'm 42
so maybe the Bears don't have the
biggest bandwagon look look I think you
designers had the biggest bandwagon on
I love Shanahan and I love what John
Lynch is doing by the way did you see
that they did that each position group I
saw these inviting guests to come from
the community whether it's kids or
at-risk kids everybody's picking like a
certain charity to bring in a happy to
bring them in as a guest I mean so Lynch
it I mean they're doing it so right I
think Jerick McKinnon could be a
spectacular addition type player there
yet right terrible
they're terrible in wins five games now
they're Vegas win totals nine like
that's insane isn't it yeah I mean I
look I don't think they're there yet
from a roster Sam are you going there
later on yeah I'll be there on Sunday
okay I like I think what Kyle's a guy I
think Kyle's going to get there I mean I
think we forget like they were
oh and I at the beginning last year they
still have a lot of work to do I like I
don't think the defense of talents quite
there yet and that's not a knock on
anybody I think it takes a few drafts I
mean that was a mess that they inherited
right like they went through I mean it
was Harbaugh Tomsula chip like three
coaches in three years and like they had
to like get that play that place was
sideways harder me thinks this could be
that breakout season that everybody's
talking about cuz you never know with
Garoppolo right first tier quarterback
talent that Belichick is still in touch
with because he's clearly knows what a
type of kid that he is everybody thinks
that Belichick is standing like John
Cusack with the boom box outside maybe
he's just loves the kid you know and he
knows who he is and he thinks he's great
or or wait for it that the Niners and
the rest of the NFC West won't even come
within two games of the Rams this year
that the Rams are that much far in a way
better than the rest of that divot the
Rams er could easily make that case the
Rams are talented there are a lot of
personalities in that locker room and so
say if they were to lose a couple games
early you had a keep Talib into the mix
you add in Dominic ensue into the mix
why why were those guys available why
were those guys available Marcus Peters
why were those guys available here's the
thing
like I just I think that that having
Shaun McVeigh has given them and I think
Shaun is dynamic and is gonna be a great
coach credit great head coach in the NFL
for a long long time they've put a lot
on him right like I think that having
Shaun McVeigh has given them a license
to bring in these personalities cast a
wider net as far as who then really a
way to but it's a challenge but a lot of
these guys are gonna be in weight room
and obviously Shaun McVeigh runs the
whole thing yeah
but it you know things won't wait in
Dallas so you think who wins the NFC
West I said I was picked out I okay I
will pick the Rams I would pick the Rams
and I think Shawn will figure it out I'm
just saying like there's ten there's a
really great talent on that roster
there's a lot of personalities too and I
think to some degree you have to have
strong guys in the locker room
who are able to when this is part of the
problem in Miami one of the reasons why
they got rid of in Tomic ensue right and
Jarvis Landry and those guys is when
things went sideways it wasn't that sue
or Landry were awful it was that they
didn't do anything to straighten him out
and so I think with the Rams it's like
who is that guy in that locker room you
know who that guy would be be Aaron
Donald what do you think the deal is
with him right now actually put a pin in
that the Honda inside a report for the
moment has brought to you by the
sizzling deals of the Hamas Honda's
summer spectacular event heat up your
summer with incredible deals in the
Accord pilot an HRV hurry into your
local Honda dealer before the Sun sets
on these great deals
Aaron Donald I want the latest on him
what other camps have you visited so far
I've been to nine so Colts bear bears
lions Browns Vikings Packers Patriots
Ravens at nine nine nines today grams is
nine grams today okay when we come back
I want to ask you as much as I possibly
can get out of those teams with you
Albert beer here of the mm QB in person
here on the Rich Eisen show looking a
little less tan than the last time I saw
that photograph no filter oh that's
right no filter greatest skill is my is
my ability to tan top it's a sad fact
about me my greatest skills my abilities
okay and troll people on Twitter good
one all right welcome back to the rich
guys and shale radio audience TV
audiences seeing the photograph but Mr
Graham with a little selfie with Albert
I got a few more camps to get back there
we watched we watch the the France guys
were watching watching France versus
whoever the heck they were beating at
the time I saw that I was blinded by
Albert's tan out at the beach like every
single day when I know you're not a
training camp right now I mean you're I
mean I'm not that far off okay I get a
few more camps under my dog but you know
what might have hurt me was yesterday it
rained in Indianapolis we were indoors
so if I'd been outside Indianapolis I
might've been a little closer
Albert knew
for the mm QB Albert Bears first class
problems practice bubbles will kill your
10 the mmq be calm practice bubbles will
kill your 10 how did luck look to you
that's another big storyline but it's
awesome I like though there was a
throwing me at ey Hilton down the
sidelines where it's just kind of like
wow like okay any any quarterback would
be proud of making this throw was kind
of like what I went what went through my
my head and you know I think one thing
when you talk to enough people there and
I talked to Ballard about it and Reich
about it he's very bad at hiding his
he's very bad at like hiding his mood
right like he's just and you've been
around him he's just like almost like
like overly genuine you know very
comfortable in his own well he's the one
who helps people get up off the turf
after they've Sam Wright tells them good
hit right right as NFL Films is heard is
picked up on the mics and he means it
like way to go yeah and so it was
interesting it was interesting talking
to the guys about it because they all
said like you could see how down he was
last year and there was really a turning
point in January and Ballard told me he
said you know it was we had been we had
tried to get him to the point where he
would tell us the truth and he would
tell the doctors the truth but he was
you know with every quarterback you sure
your toughness through availability so
every quarterback hides stuff and they
needed to get to the point where he was
being honest about it
and Ballard told me that in January luck
came to him and said I don't need the
surgery I'm gonna be fine we're gonna
work through this and that's where they
sort of launched the step by step by
step program and I look they're
optimistic about it what I saw yesterday
in Indianapolis was really impressive I
think he'll be out there week one
without a problem
the question then becomes what
percentage of Andrew Luck are we getting
they're confident that it's gonna be a
hundred percent of what he was but I
think that's the question is what
version of Andrew Luck are we getting
you know Indianapolis I'm just checking
out week one against the Bengals I mean
you want to talk about teams that you
have no idea who they could be this year
Colts are one of them Bengals are know
kind of another yeah I mean they could
like they get the offensive line fixed
with Cory Glen and Billy price maybe
there can get back to where they were
you know division Baltimore like
Baltimore can go either way
you know to me have you seen Baltimore
yeah the team's okay how the hell are
they gonna work
the Flacco Lamar Jackson I don't know
right now the story is that Flacco has
been rejuvenated okay
FLAC make Flacco elite again is
basically that the storyline over there
because Lamar has lit a fire under him
he's in shape right look great and
winning football game is just gonna be
that just win and there's no problem
yeah but Lamar Jackson has gotta be on
the field every snap he's too damn
dynamic to keep off the field every
stairs this yes every sense yes yes yes
unless he's your quarterback in the
future then you can't afford out you
can't afford to get him hurt so I mean
so that's what I'm saying is you but
he's so dynamic let's say Flacco has on
occasion one of his with all due respect
usual the clunkers where all of a sudden
they just can't seem to get that first
down right and Justin you know and
Tucker's gonna have to win the damn game
for this leg if I kick in nineteen fifty
orders like and and so you're not gonna
you're not gonna try and get the ball in
the March actions hands and those well I
know like some of the stuff that they've
talked about as far as Flacco goes like
and I know they feel this way do you
know over the last three years he's the
31st rated quarterback in the NFL like
he is bottom of the barrel over the last
three years since he lost Gary Kubiak
after the 2014 season their investment
is way up here yeah and production has
been way down there and so they they had
these discussions about it and I think
part of the benefit of drafting Lamar
Jackson wasn't will get answers on Joe
Flacco now we'll know what he has left
because he's been hurt a lot the last
few years
look I mean I think that we're gonna see
Lamar in spots the way he runs like it
was interesting watching him the way he
runs it looks like Randy Moss I know
that's a weird comparison to make
because he's a receiver but the way he
glides and just separates from people
and you know it's like kind of like that
you you don't realize how fast he's
moving until you like look at him start
to separate so he's gotta be on the feet
right and they're gonna and I think
they'll find a way they'll find a way to
use him if he's gonna play quarterback
it's gonna boil down to the team I don't
think it's even Flacco I think it's the
team because look III
study on this the last ten draft classes
2008 to 2017 right 27 quarterbacks went
in the first round only to true red
shirts one was Jake Locker in 2011 one
was Pat mahomes last year what are those
two have in common they both played for
teams that contended to the end of the
year the Titans were 9 and 7 the Chiefs
won their division and so I think that
the way that the only way you're gonna
keep Lamar Jackson from playing
quarterback this year it's not even
about League 5 who could play well if
the team's not contending I think you're
gonna see Lamar Jackson at quarterback
because they're gonna need answers and
what adds another layer to this is the
fact that there's transition in that
organization that Ozzie Newsome is gonna
be handing over the reins to Erik
decosta in January and they have made
the playoffs in three years and they
could be going through a quarterback
transition so there's a lot of moving
pieces there and the most impressive
team you've seen so far the Vikings I
think to me it's uh you look at some of
the things they didn't have last year
and you watch them in practice Mike is
very easy to forget Dalvin cook because
he only played a month last year right
but my god was he electrical wasn't
wasn't wearing a brace and you watch him
and you've been out at these practices
they weren't even wearing pads but you
know like when it almost looks like
somebody sees things faster and then
it's moving faster than everybody else
and that's what Cook looked like so add
that and add Kirk Cousins to what they
already had offensively and then you
look at Sheldon Richardson physically
and what he could bring with all the
other pieces they have defensively they
look like they're loaded and it's gonna
be interesting to see them coming back
off of a bad loss in the NFC
Championship game Kirk Cousins is now in
a very different position I mean he's
been under a lot of pressure the last
three years right
playing for contracts not necessarily
entrenched as the starting quarterback
long term now he's got his contract
he's entrenched there how is that going
to affect him they've got a new
offensive coordinator and John D Flippo
they're gonna be installing some of the
RPO stuff we saw in Philly they're just
they're very talented and there's just a
lot of intriguing storylines there and
they've added pieces whether it's a guy
coming back from injury and a cook or
free agents like Cousins and Richardson
that make that should send the signal to
everyone in that locker room our front
office believes that weren't in a
championship window there's pressure on
us to win now yeah but then there's the
guy that bar knocked down last year
right who's back which is why and Aaron
Rodgers which is why when people have
asked me is Minnesota the easy pick in
the north no no as long as as long as
Aaron Rodgers is upright the Packers
have a shot and look Jimmy Graham looked
great the day I was there Jimmy Graham
looked great
they brought in marseilles DS Louis one
of the things that a couple of you there
pointed out to me is when we had great
success offensively we've generally had
two tight ends it's allowed us to play
some matchups with Aaron
they Davante Adams look great the day I
was there and they made an interesting
hire and adding Mike Patton
you know they've been mediocre on
defense the last few years Don keep Dom
Capers have been there for nine years
you bring in Patton and now they've got
all these big long corners they drafted
Josh Jackson they drafted junior
Alexander Kevin Kings a second-year
player for them they look like a
different team you know like like it has
for the last ten years everything boils
down to whether or not Rogers is healthy
but if he is you can't count him out is
it true he gave up dairy in Wisconsin
yeah he it's it's you know what he like
likes to explain this to me he said when
you when you get injured like that you
come to a crossroads and you decide okay
I'm either dreading going through the
rehab and getting myself back in the
field or I can't wait to get back and he
said that he immediately got that
feeling can't wait to get back what was
so interesting about it was he said to
me like he couldn't like I can't use
that chip from 2005 anymore right like
that chip on his shoulder being in the
green room watching 23 picks come and go
and he's not he's not coming off the
board that was what drove him early in
his career and that's gone now and so he
said his motivation now is longevity is
can I get to 40 years old and be playing
at this level and one of the people that
he's used as a resource in order to get
there has been Tom Brady and so he's
following a lot of the now it's not to
the tee it may not be like the avocado
ice cream and all that stuff but he's
following a lot of what Tom Brady did
now to try and get himself to playing at
40 because that's sort of his new
challenge you want
quick 60-second break come back Albert
and I have spent a half an hour avoiding
the elephant in the room oh okay
I've spent a full half-hour picking your
football bra a restraint okay when we
come out there are a lot of fans want to
know what you think of what's going on
and on okay Tate since you do represent
that school pretty much every single day
yeah okay we're back with Albert beer in
60 seconds on that and more a one more
segment with Albert Breer a senior
writer of the mmq be here on a Western
Swing of his training camp tour heading
to the Rams as soon as we're done here
right Cowboys and I assume you Chargers
yeah and up north and then up north so
you're gonna go to Oxnard a Cowboys
I mean that's fine but that's one of the
wife doesn't feel sorry for me from the
travel I mean and that's how Charles
Woodson became a vintner you know yeah
he who spent all those years with the
Raiders right and him being an Ohio guy
who went to the state of Michigan to
play for perfect segue okay Albert I'm
gonna give you the floor a lot of folks
are wondering what Urban knew when he
knew it what happened with the latest
story were the wife of Zack Smith yeah
the wide receiver coach revealing a text
exchange he had with Urban's wife mouth
being assaulted by her soon-to-be
ex-husband and at the time in 2015 wide
receiver coach of Ohio State letting her
know what's going on and I did I get
that right yeah and he I mean I think
that the other point you add here is
that it the receivers coach was Earl
Bruce's grandson or L Bruce was the guy
in urban said it like you know probably
the most impactful mentor that he had I
mean look you know there are some things
that are way beyond what we cover and
domestic violence clearly is one of them
and one of the things that I've learned
covering the NFL and then really I think
for all of us you included right-looking
was 2015 2015 I 2014 it like when you
had rice and Peterson and Hardy
you know you sort of learn to be very
very careful about what you say about
these things because you don't know you
don't know like you have to let the
facts come out I think we all learned
that in Josh Brown too or Josh Brown
like it looked like one thing and then
that journal came out and all of a
sudden it was something it was if people
see tapes then obviously they take it a
little bit more seriously but if if if
ermine knew I mean it's hot again and he
got up there in the podium and he said I
mean look that's that's what got Jim
Tressel fired right like Jim Tressel got
fired not because of the tattoo scandal
but because he wasn't truthful about it
and so you know I think that's gonna
that's the biggest piece now going
forward is you know did Shelly Mayer it
is why Shelly Meyer communicate to Urban
Meyer and if she did then like it has he
like and and not only like like what he
said at Big Ten media days which is bad
not but like was that what he told the
athletic directors that we told the
university like there are a lot of
questions that need to be answered here
and I mean I I look no matter where I
went to school like these are the most
like like some of the most serious
matters that any of us and I don't cover
college football but like my time
covering the NFL like outside of the
Aaron Hernandez thing the most serious
things we've covered are the domestic
violence things and so you know one of
the things that again that I've learned
is that they're very complex and I you
know like we have to let it play out and
you know if he knew if he knew and he
lied to the University or lied to to
Gene Smith the athletic director about
it you know then this would be this this
this would be one where you know you
could see and wind up suffering the same
sort of fate Jim Tressel did and we
don't know that yet so are all your
buddies you're Ohio state but yeah
that's a I've got a pretty active tech
situation going now yeah
Albert Brewer here on the Rich Eisen
show so I guess then to be fair and
balanced I'll ask you the question that
any thoughts on chickens
by coordinating producer Don Bowie and
Chris Brockman have been wanting asked
over and over again on the show and I'll
ask em okay good which Harbaugh needs to
win more this year John or Jim do you
think Albert prieur it's a good question
I'm gonna say John because there's gonna
be a change in leadership in Baltimore
where I think the people at Michigan are
very invested in Jim Harbaugh because
there's a change in leadership I think
anytime there's a change in leadership
that puts pressure on everybody in the
building and we know that is happening
right now
like we know right now that Ozzie
Newsome is handing the reins to Eric
DeCosta and so I think that puts
everyone in the building and notice
where as you know I think with Michigan
there are people who have invested so
heavily in Jim Harbaugh that if Jim
Harbaugh fails then is their failure to
you know and so and I think I mean look
fair and balanced
I think Michigan's can be really good
this well Shay Patterson is gonna be the
the big yeah but the defense should be
Western but it should be too we should
see and your your snide comment moments
ago are you denying that a chicken is
not an anxious bird have you stopped
are you saying are you saying that the
chicken is not a nervous bird you know
my two-year-old my two year old
shout-out to Drew my two year old drew
drew drew Briere abrir drew brees a that
sounds very close to to a quarterback by
the way it's Andrew okay Andrew Bria
okay yeah but but drew actually walks
right up to chickens and they aren't
anxious around him and he's very like he
can be a little like you know sudden
with his movements and everything else I
never noticed that the the chickens were
particularly anxious around him have you
stopped eating chicken now no I eat
chicken I don't think it makes me
nervous but if if that if that helps win
football games then I'm I'm all for for
a meet we did get off the beaten path a
little bit because we were promised some
news that your thoughts on what's going
on with Aaron Don
the Rams before you go out the door
there go to the Rams yeah what do you
think I think it's a fascinating
situation it applies to Clio Mac too and
I think with Clio Mac it might be a
little bit more of the actual cash that
the Raiders are gonna have to shell out
but when Adamic ensue signed his deal
with the dolphins three years ago he was
making 86 percent of what the top
quarterback was making okay the market
on defensive players hasn't moved since
then
yet Von Miller basically seemed like a
signed the same contract a year later
okay so that was three years ago
so what sue and what Miller are making
or what sue was making what Miller is
making is now 63 percent of what the top
quarterbacks making right when Matt Ryan
signed his deal
the quarterbacks broke the thirty
million dollar barrier before any other
player broke twenty million dollars so I
think what Donald and what what Donald
and Mac are looking for is a market
correction right they say there's three
years of inflation here we've seen
inflation at receiver we've seen
inflation now at running back with Todd
Gurley we've seen inflation at
quarterback we believe the market needs
to be corrected and if let's just say
it's 80 percent let's say 80 take 86 out
of the table i off the table 80% of what
Matt Ryan's making that's 24 million
dollars a year so is the response safe
from less need and from Mackenzie up in
Oakland like don't hold us responsible
because the Dolphins lost their minds
with in Dhamma can sue and in terms of
Vaughn go win a Super Bowl MVP before
you ask for that contract it could be it
could be but like then you could turn
around to les Snead and say well you
gave Todd Gurley a market correction
right I mean that was a market
correction that what's the answer here
well and what's this August 7th date IQ
the August 7th day so if they don't get
if if he doesn't show up by August 7th
which is next Tuesday and he doesn't get
credited for the year towards free
agency and because Aaron Donald already
blew past that deadline once he did it
last year he only has three years which
means he'd be a restricted free agent
after the year now the Rams would have
to make the decision do they might still
franchise him anyway and it may have
zero effect and I think Donald's feeling
would be if you make me an RFA
then somebody's gonna turn over a
first-round pick for me so I'm not that
worried about it but it is a it is sort
of a milestone well you know deadlines
for action will it's for action do you
think like I wouldn't rule anything out
I know both I know in both cases the
tooth the sides are far apart and
they've had trouble finding a middle
ground I think the ultimate leverage for
both these players right for both Mac
and Donald have we ever heard of either
of these guys doing anything wrong off
the field no how about in the locker
room no okay what kind of players have
they been right defensive players the
year so I think for a Rams team is very
clearly sent the message where win now
and for a Raiders team that needs to
have players get on board with Jon
Gruden but they do you're doing
everything you can and then it's like
like it can it can mess with your
chemistry if there's that guy out there
and you're not taking care of him it can
it can screw up the message a little bit
and so I think that that I for for
Donald and Mac that's the best leverage
but it's a hard thing because those guys
are those guys are I have been looking
for a market correction and it's a fair
point right like it's a fair point it's
also if you're the team's you're looking
at you're saying we're not responsible
for the market like we're willing to
give you an incremental raise but we're
not gonna blow up the market to get this
done so last one for you Rams at Raiders
last game opening weekend of the season
a Monday and I was warned that you guys
had a poll question yesterday on this
right well we we just were wondering who
questioned some of the poll question
yesterday
yesterday's game shows yeah game sure
great Martindale's to use the fridge
outperform performed uh Rams and Raiders
who's gonna be playing in that game best
guess right now so you're sitting here
we send you out the door to both teams I
think both have the resolve to be kam
chancellor the way the kam chancellor
was a few years ago but but but I
personally think right now it would be
more likely that Aaron Donald will be
there I think based on what the Rams
have done and taking care of their
players based on how creative kevin
damoff less need Tony piss tours the
guys who do the contracts are have been
and based on the fact that they got a
girl tag early done deal which was
enormous ly difficult because there was
no model for it I think that Donald be
there week one I would be a little less
sure on clear back thanks for doing this
again how other let's make this an
annual tree four years in a row is one
it already has one safe
safe journeys around the country and
next year better tan right I gotta
maintain your Stewart tan game is still
on point it just wasn't as OnPoint as
the last time I saw it it's okay
practice bubbles will do that that's
okay it's first class problems you also
asked a question or a rhetorical one
what the hell's going on with Bryce
Harper yeah off there we're gonna have
that at the top of the next hour Chelsea
jeans of the Washington Post when we
come back an incredible old gents tat
from last night don't you dare move here
on the Richardson show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience